se abrió con una canción llamada
1994 que detalla la deportación forzada
de tártaros de la península de crimea
as
[Música]
y
la primera plataforma de crimea iniciada
porque es una cumbre que tiene como
objetivo devolver pacíficamente la
península de crimea al control de
ucrania después de que ésta fuera tomada
por el kremlin en 2014
la plataforma de crimea debe convertirse
en un punto focal para tomar todas las
decisiones claves sobre crimen
dónde cráneos
y hoy anunciamos oficialmente la cuenta
regresiva para cuando crimen sea
desocupada
aunque para hacer esto selenski
reconoció que el kremlin tendría que
sentarse en la mesa de negociaciones y
aunque la cumbre atrajo a representantes
de docenas de países incluida la unión
europea y la otan vladimir putin estuvo
ausente en cambio asistió a los juegos
militares internacionales de rusia el
foro busca aumentar la presión sobre
moscú incluso con la coordinación de
sanciones internacionales efectivas y
ayudar a la región a superar el impacto
económico tras la toma
estoy aquí para reafirmar la postura
inquebrantable de la unión europea no
reconocemos ni reconoceremos la anexión
ilegal de crimea y sebastopol por parte
de rusia
antes de la cumbre selenski converso con
la canciller alemana angela merkel para
asegurarse de que ucrania no sufrirá
tras la culminación del gasoducto nord
stream 2 que exportará gas de rusia a
europa a través del mar báltico